is live in delhi for us now and neville
she's a huge name isn't she and the fact
that there's a national mourning
gives you a clear indication of that
absolutely right the national warnings
for two days all flags in the country
have been
are at half mast
she's going to be given a state funeral
the prime minister himself flying down
from here from delhi to uh to mumbai to
attend that later this evening just
tells you how important and what an icon
she has been if you actually think of it
it's you can
her
her reign
in in in indian cinema right from the
top uh you could call it from frank
sinatra to adele that's the kind of
bandwidth she had and always at the top
of her of of
of her game she brought back playback
singing back into a limelight while
earlier playback singers were always
kept hidden but she made made sure they
were back in the center of indian cinema
which permeates every part of our
society for generations she's basically
transcended all these generations for
the last 70 80 years and she is an
absolute icon uh doing singing more than
uh 15 000 uh songs and and these songs
are part of mo of hundreds of films and
it is a very important aspect of indian
society here in india culturally and
traditionally hindi cinema permeates
every part of our society and has great
influence
amongst generations out here and it will
it is definitely a big loss to the
country and the continent and the world
of music